so I hate to do this but I made a bet
with someone and I need your help to win
hey Justine I found the animal Twitter
now I bet you couldn't get on her shell
oh yeah Justine well I bet I can okay
well maybe the bet was with myself but
that's beside the point
okay Twitter army let some pic this
happen all you gotta do is Twitter to
Ellen at The Ellen Show have a die
Justine on your show so get tweeting and
in the meantime I'm gonna go do the
Twitter dance okay everybody do let's
wait to dance
it might look silly at your first glance
pick up your phone and go from left to
right and do the Twitter dance all day
and all night
everybody do the Twitter dance and bang
look silly at the first glance up the
phone and go from left to right and do
this with a dance all ban on die set
everybody do the Twitter's dance twitter
twitter twitter